you mentioned right before uh telling
the story of this elaborate scam that
you were on federal probation how did
that happen so I mentioned that I I own
the mortgage company yes right so I I
had started a mortgage company I had
maybe a dozen guys working for me and
and there was fraud you know like I
would say it wasn't all fraud but
whatever 60 70% of it was fraud that was
going in there and from the outside of
that that business it looked very legit
it you know we were an FHA approved
lender we were a VA approved lender we
did
conventional probably signed up with 40
or 50 subprime
lenders um but but there was a
considerable amount of Fraud and you
know it kept
getting you know it it became a game
right you know it you start you I
started getting just more and more
creative like like I said every time I
would get away with something like you
become emboldened by it it's like nice
you know like hey the underwriter's
looking for this and looking for this
and you sit there and go man so that
she's you know that's what am I going to
do what am I you know what we could do
we could create create our own bank what
yeah here's what we're gonna do we're
going to go on like how do they know if
this Bank exists these people are in
California or they're in New York like
they don't know so what we're going to
do is we're going to go online and keep
in mind this is 2000 you know this is
2000 2001 like this is the internet
in its infancy still right so we figure
out I remember GoDaddy I think had just
come up with a site where you could
build your own website like how cool is
that so I go online with a buddy of mine
and we create something called the bank
of ebore you know we cut and pasted
things that we like from other Banks and
we got a 1 1800 number you could call or
186 number whatever it was and you could
call it and it would go to a voicemail
and so we set up this bank and then I
ended up making bank statements which by
this point I already had been making
bank statements to to prove someone has
their down payment because a lot of
times people they have good enough
credit to borrow 95% or 90% but they
don't have their down payment so we'd
raise the purchase price high enough to
cover their 5 or 10% down payment and we
would bring their down payment for them
or we'd have the owner of the house
bring the down payment for them and then
we would have a cut out of the closing
statement to a construction
company that I owned and we get our
money back so they get into the house
for 100% financing or 110% some of them
turned into 130 we want to pay off their
car give them an incentive to
sign um they don't have still don't have
the money to buy it so we're doing all
kinds of insane things well at some
point remember Gretchen Zas my uh um my
old manager yeah the original OG she
came and worked for me for a short
period of time and then she and her
husband went and opened their own
mortgage company which you should have
known it was going to be fraudulent from
the B go because it was called creative
financing it was was yeah create C uh
CFM creative Finance no creative
creative was in the name yeah yeah
creative was in the name oh boy um so
it's really on the not
so she uh she's doing very
well and and we became very close by the
way we we go on vacation went to Puerto
Rico together um I'm I got married at
the time I got I was
married our kids you know play together
we babysit we go to each other's parties
we're close we're good friends and she's
got her own mortgage company she calls
me up periodically and ask me hey can
you make a W2 or hey can you make me a
pay stub sure no problem we're friends
that that's what fraudulent friends do
so you know if I needed somebody to to
verify rent or verify somebody's um
rental history or employment she had
cell phon she would answer that sort of
thing for me well what ends up happening
is um she gets in trouble she starts
doing fraudulent loans for some guys you
know and
these guys are doing what's called a
cash back scam MH so they're they're
getting like a half a million dollar
loan on a house that's
worth $300,000 so they're getting a
they're buying the house for whatever
600,000 it's really only worth 300
350 but she happened to be in an area
where she could get it the appraisal
jacked up so they they buy the house
they get $2 $300,000 back
and um it's it's a it's a straw man scam
right it's a cashback straw man scam so
it's a real person that's buying the
house he's got perfect credit but he's
willing he's willing to let to ruin his
credit to get a couple hundred thousand
in his pocket so he never has any
intentions so it's not a synthetic
identity it's not a stolen identity it's
a straw man he's a fake kind of a not a
fake person but he's just a straw man
he's a standing so he stands in he signs
the paperwork he buy buys the house they
end up getting two 300,000 well this guy
buys like five houses so it's A2 three
million they've lost five 600 six
700,000 and these guys never even make
the first payment they just let them go
into a foreclosure so the bank
immediately investigates and realizes
this is fraud so the FBI comes in they
grab Pete and Gretchen she has to hire
an attorney of course and she doesn't
get thrown in jail or anything they just
come to their office and they they tell
them they're investigating them they
know what's going on and they they want
to talk to they're like look we want to
talk to you and you're going to be in
inded okay so she comes to me well
actually Pete came to me and said look
man can you refinance our house and get
a 75,000 out to pay our attorney I said
no problem
um Gretchen gives me W2s pay subs fake
the whole thing's fake I get her I
refinance I get a second mortgage on our
house $755,000 they pay their attorney
their attorney immediately says you need
to wear a wire on this guy like he just
got you $775,000 you know I don't know
how you got $775 ,000 but the attorney
knows something's wrong because the
attorney's like they just your whole
mortgage company was just shut down
there's no way you could borrow
$75,000 so he's like this this guy's
doing fraudulent stuff and she says yes
of course he is and he says you need to
work with the FBI wear a wire against
this
guy so she calls me one day and says
listen I got to talk to you the FBI is
asking questions about you and I go what
and she goes yeah I was like um meet me
at the pizza place down the street so
you don't come in my office cuz
everybody knows she's been indicted like
everybody in her office quit when the
FBI the FBI shows up and gives you a
business card and announces they're the
FBI everybody quits so I said do not
have do not don't don't come here
because they already know they're
already concerned so I go and I meet her
and Pete and we sit down at the uh at a
restaurant you know a little Pizzeria
and I sit down and she starts telling me
that the FBI is asking questions about
me and I'm like what are you talking
about like what are they asking she goes
look they came in they took all our
files and like I was like I didn't know
any of this I'm like when did this
happen she's like yeah they a couple
weeks ago and they they and they have
some of your files cuz I had closed
several loans for my wife at the time we
were buying rental properties my wife
didn't have a job so there there it's
all fraud but I couldn't clo I could not
close those loans in at my mortgage
company because I own the property so
I'm selling those properties I bought
properties rent renovated them and sold
them to my wife to get around something
called seasoning seasoning says you have
to wait 6 months to a year to refinance
at the market value otherwise you if you
want to refinance that's fine but you
have to refinance at the price you
purchase the property at but I bought
these properties for 80 or 100,000
renovated them sold them for two 300,000
to my my wife who got a very got didn't
even get a big mortgage we were just
trying to kind of get around a a
um a guideline so but my wife was not
working and I provided W2s and pay subbs
so when she says all this she says yeah
they're looking at at your the loans you
gave me at at your wife's loans and I
went oh my God I said well you didn't
tell them that the W2s were fake did you
you didn't tell them the pay stubs were
fake did you you didn't tell them that
the down payments were you didn't tell
them that we were married did you I mean
just absolutely buried myself and as I'm
telling her this
I was like I I I I was like I I kind of
caught myself and I okay wait wa wait a
minute look okay here's what you're
going to tell them you're going to tell
them you never met her she called on the
phone like I start trying to devise a
plan that will answer their questions
without getting my wife in trouble or
them in trouble and if nobody cooperates
the whole thing should shut down you
know they it doesn't go anywhere there's
no way there's nowhere for them to go if
everybody just kind of stonewalls
them so as I'm saying all
this Gretchen says Matt we can't lie to
the FBI and I go what are you talking
about you're already lying to the FBI I
mean you you you know you you've been
lying to the FBI I mean I just
refinanced your house and before I can
really say
anything Pete jumps up her husband
stands up and he says we've never lied
to the FBI we may not have told them
everything but we've never
lied and I thought
like what what who like who are you
talking to like I know that's not true
so you're not saying that for my benefit
so I was just I kind of look at him and
I'm like what and I just I remember
looking down and and this may mean
nothing but both of their cell phones
were right next to me right and I
remember they were probably just wearing
wires but I just remember thinking those
cell phones are microphones they
probably weren't but I remember thinking
oh wow and I just I looked at and I went
wow and I said well I hope you're going
to get something for this you she
immediately starts crying and she says
Matt I'm sorry I I have a kid I can't go
to jail do you have kids at that point
yeah I like I have a kid like I have a
kid and I was like wow I wow what have
you learned about friendship from that
like loyalty oh yeah there's no there's
that's a that's it's sweet that must
have hurt it's cute I mean I I love the
idea of it you don't think that no I'll
tell you why so
I go back to my I go back to my office I
remember I told her I said tell the FBI
agent to call me on the phone do not
come in my office so I go back I'm still
trying to figure out how to weather this
right I go back I sit
down phone rings uh my secretary comes
in and says hey agent I'll never forget
a guy's name agent Scott Gil with the
FBI and I was like okay is on the phone
and she's standing there I was like
close the door like get out and close
she's
like so get on the phone he asked me if
I'll come down I said yeah absolutely
let's schedule it for next Tuesday you I
put it off four or five days um I go to
my brother-in-law immediately who's a
who's a uh a lawyer and he says oh yeah
yeah I don't really tell him exactly
what's going on but I tell him this is
what's happening kind of and I'm I may
be in trouble I need a I need a federal
defense attorney I don't even know what
a federal defense I don't even know the
difference but he said you need a
federal defense attorney it's the FBI so
he we go on a couple we meet a couple
lawyers I end up getting a lawyer I give
give him like 75 grand um and he started
to have me convinced initially he had me
convinced I was probably going to go to
jail for a few years but really that's
what they kind of do to justify you
giving them $75,000 right and then but
the more I thought about it that you
know and and read he gave me the
guidelines that that supposedly I had I
had um you know the the fraud that I had
committed and what the guy and the
guidelines that oversaw that um and I
read it and I was like I'm not really in
trouble here because I'm looking at a
felony but I'm not going to go to jail
because there was no potential for the
bank to lend to lose money
so because I bought the house with like
a hard money loan and then I renovated
it with my own cash and when I sold it
it appraised at
250,000 my my uh ex-wife borrowed like
180 so there's plenty of of it if the
whole thing had gone into foreclosure
they still would have got their money
back and to be honest by the time all of
this happened there was only like three
of the three properties it was like five
but we'd already sold a few and at this
point we had just sold another two
there's like one or two properties left
so we're selling at that moment we were
selling them so I I was like no I kind
of argue with him but then he wanted 75
grand I gave him 75 grand and then he
comes back and he says good news there
was no potential fraud so I can get you
three years now here's the thing here's
here's what I always kind of look back
at when I first got went into his office
he
said he said listen you haven't been
indicted yet I spoke with the FBI I
spoke with the US
attorney they believe and they've been
told and he said look they didn't tell
me exactly what they have but they said
with the the evidence that they have on
you based on two confidential
informants that it it's you cannot go to
trial and I was like right but of course
I knew that and I was like okay he said
but he said you haven't been indicted
yet and they are fairly certain that
you're running um a mill right a fraud
Mill over there and you guys are
churning out fraudulent loans now they
can't come and they can't come and raid
your office and do anything about it yet
because so far they only have you but
here's what I'm saying is that he said I
can keep you from being
indicted it's called um
pre-trial is a pre-trial
intervention where we go in and what
we'll do what we'll do is you go you
work you go in talk to the FBI you go
grab a bunch of your mortgage broker
most egregious
files grab them bring those files to the
FBI go work with the FBI they will
indict them and you will not be indicted
and I said
which I I kick myself to this day I said
absolutely not I'm not going to snitch
on them I'm not going to cooperate I'm
not going to you know I'd seen The
Godfather you're not supposed to
cooperate you're supposed to be loyal
I'm not going to do any of that and you
know and and so I say all of
this where you know looking back like I
I would have if I could go back in time
I would have gone into our weekly
meeting with a dolly and I would walked
in front of everybody and scooped up two
or three of the file cabinets and put
them in the back of a truck and said
listen you guys are going to be talking
to the FBI soon I suggest you get
attorneys and I would have dri driven
off but I didn't I thought no be
loyal you know don't do that and and
what happened
was when my when the other thing falls
apart right when the next scam falls
apart every one of these people go to
the FBI like they're not even coming to
them these guys are going to the FBI
with lawyers I want to cooperate I want
to tell you what Cox did I want to help
I want to and I'm think like I never had
to get indicted to begin with so you
think that most of these people from
your experience are going to uh
sacrifice all integrity that's a funny
word sacrifice sure that applies to this
but
that's they're going to
sacrifice friendships and loyalty for
just the Sav their own ass yeah that I
only had one person that did not talk to
the FBI I had one person that every time
the FBI or the Secret Service went to
that person's door she said don't come
to my house again I don't have anything
to say about about Matt I have nothing
to do with any of this talk to my lawyer
and this happened over and over again
and that's my ex-wife she's a
gangster